yes so I'm going to talk about graph
algorithms for modern data models just a
bit of apology since it's uh a general
audience I'm not talking about our
latest results but that does mean that
some of you in the audience have seen
them before so in particular Andrew so
so if you feel free to yourself just uh
turn yourself
off so over the past decade many
commonly dist many commodity distributed
computing platforms have emerged and two
major examples a map reduce uh which is
uh which everyone has heard of and
distributed stream processing which is
also quite common it's just that there's
no one unifying platform the way Hado is
for M you so it's um it's less well
there's less commonality around
different ways of doing distribut stream
processing these are similar to Pam
models but they have several nuances
they're carefully calibrated to take
latencies of dis versus networks versus
memory into account and cost of
processing is often negligible compared
to the cost of data trans or the cost of
reading from
disk and these these these models they
take advantage of aggregation in disk
and in network operations for example
the cost of sending 100 kilobytes is
about the same as sending one byte over
a network because you still have to
reserve space on the underlying physical
Channel you still have to send some
token over it has to go through your
whole processing stack and at that point
whether it's you're processing and you
still have to process the whole
header so you might as well just
aggregate everything together and send
them over and so the first data model
that we're going to talk about about is
map R use that it takes advantage of
this aggregation it's an immensly
successful idea which is transformed
offline analytics and bulk data
processing and Hadoop which initially
came from Yahoo is the most popular
implementation and so it's got three
phases the first phase is what's called
a map in a map you transform a key value
pair into other key value pairs using a
user defined function called map so map
is both a phase in the computation as
well as the user defined function it's
overloaded notation many mappers can run
in in parallel on vast amounts of data
in a distributed file system then
Shuffle is just an infrastructure phase
the programmer never sees Shuffle the
infrastructure then transfers data from
the mapper nodes to the reducer nodes so
that all the key value pairs with the
same key go to the same reducer and get
grouped into a single large key comma
Val one Val two pair and a reducer a
reduce is a user defined function also
an infrastructure phase that process
processes this group key comma Val one
Val two pair for a single key and many
reducers can run in
parallel one difficulty with trying to
do algorithms for Hado is that there's
no well established notion of complexity
measures for had the complexity measures
which are sort of more about what can be
comput which pertain more to what can be
computed in polinomial time on Hadoop uh
but there's nothing which allows you to
do detailed analysis and so this is an
attempt to do a detailed performance
model for had and so we have complexity
measures which are divided into two
classes key complexity and sequential
complexity key complexity can be thought
of as the amount of effort you would put
into your computation if you had
infinitely many computers so infinitely
many computers the bottleneck becomes
how much time it takes to process a
single key single key value pay which
needs to happen on a single computer and
this and so and here one key measure is
the maximum size of a single key value
pair and that's often called The Curse
of the last reducer for example R is it
in papers which bring on the cursor the
last reducer for for various problems so
if your single key value pair is very
large then there'll be one reducer no
matter how many computers you have
there'll be one reducer which will take
a huge time and that's called The Curse
of the last reducer the amount of time
taken to process each key the memory
required to process each key and these
are sort of subsidary measures not not
quite as important as the maximum size
of a key value for and the next thing is
sequential complexity and you can think
of this as the amount of time it would
take if you were doing everything on a
single computer is the total time needed
by all the mappers and together and the
total output produced by all the mappers
and reducers together okay and this
and reducers together you can think of
that as a shuffle size I mean it's not
exactly a shuffle size but that's a main
component the amount of data that
transfers from the map side to the
reduced side and there's some things
which are
not modeled here and so see one thing
that's not modeled is the amount of work
done to aggregate all the values for a
single key is not a complexity measure
okay so when you send your data over
from the map the reduced side everything
which has the same key has to be grouped
together and that's that's not a
complexity measure and the reason is
that this grouping typically happens on
disk and disk is so slow that you
essentially get this sorting for
free so you do have to write to disk but
the amount of effort you take to write
your dis is already taken into account
in the shuffle size and the additional
time it would take you to sort something
is then sort of essentially you get that
for
free so the problem we going to look at
is the densest subgraph problem we given
an undirected graph g = v comma e with n
nodes M edges and maximum degree D Max
and for a subset s of nodes let e of s
denot the set of edges between nodes and
S and your goal is to find the set s
that maximizes the size of es s divided
by S so it's the densest subgraph of
this graph the application is the
community Direction the problem can be
solved in polinomial time and a 2 plus
Epsilon approximation is known on map
reduce which takes order login over
Epsilon phases so that's something I
should have mentioned another very
important complexity measure for map
reduce algorithms is the number of map
reduce phases because each phase is very
expensive to set up each phase then
requires its own synchronization its own
Shuffle and so bahmani Kumar and
vasileski gave a 2 plus Epsilon
approximation for this problem which
takes login over Epsilon phases each
phase a sequential complexity order M
and key complexity order dmax okay and
the sequential complexity and key
complexity is about the best you can
expect so you have a graph algorithm and
the graph algorithm you would unless
you're doing something really funky some
really funky sampling you would expect
that you have to at least send your
whole graph over from one side to the
other which dictates a sequential
complexity of order M and normally for
most algorithms for most reasonable
algorithms at least the edges
corresponding to a single node you have
to look at them in the same reducer
which somehow dictates a key complexity
of dmax okay so this m and dmax are
about the best equ expect log n/ Epsilon
is pretty good right so this is so this
algorithm is of like The Benchmark in
terms of complexity you can't really
expect to do much
better uh but you do you would like to
get the approximation down if
possible and so here's a simple LP
formulation for this
problem you we Define XV to indicate
whether node V is part of the set s that
we chose or not and summation over vxv
is less than equal to one that's just a
normalization factor y indicates whether
HED e e is part of the edge set or not
and so and Edge e can be in es only if
it end points are in s so you have
constraints which says that y less than
equal to XV for both end points of the
edge then maximizing you want to
maximize summation over e y while
setting summation over v x less than
equal to 1 maximizes density okay so
it's a fairly simple linear program this
LP has no integrality Gap so normally
when you write down LPS for
combinatorial problems they almost
always have integrality Gap in this case
it doesn't so we could solve this LP and
we get the exact solution in fact you
can show that if you solve this
LP uh is fairly easy to
round so the what we are going to do
instead instead of solving the lp which
is going to be very hard we're going to
find an approximate solution we're going
to write the Dual of the lp and solve
this this dual on map reduce so and so
this is this is sort of interesting
because now we taking the stand because
there many many Primal dual algorithms
known uh for various Comal problems and
so as far as we know no serious effort
has been made to try to actually solve
them on map
reduce so we're going to look at what we
call PSC type algorithms these
algorithms perform multiplicative
updates of dual wees it's a it's a
powerful Primal dual
technique and so when I say
multiplicative updates of dual wees we
solving the Dual so it'll be like the
Dual WS of the Dual it's a powerful
Primal dual technique with many
applications online parallelized and
centralized algorithms and the approach
is going to be to formulate the Dual in
a form suitable for PST reduce the width
for efficiency and then increase width
for obtaining the Primal back from the
Dual and again I'm not going to point
out how you would do it on a sequential
computer uh but the way you would do it
would be quite
different so this is the Primal this is
the Dual
um we I've labeled the constants in the
Primal with what's going to be variables
in the Dual the summation over V XV less
than equal to one is the constant I'm
calling D for density and Y less than
equal to XV is going to be a constraint
which I'm going to call Alpha EV is
going to be a constraint for every Edge
and both notes incident on that edge and
and then the Dual ends up being
minimized d That's the only nonzero
coefficient on the right simple exercise
in taking duals and then in addition
you're going to get uh Alpha e plus
Alpha EV plus Alpha ew greater than
equal to 1 for all edges essentially
says that for every Edge you have to
assign a you have take an edge and you
have to take assign some cost for that
edge for each of his end points that the
Edge gets covered by either this end
point or that end point in in a way such
that the sum of the edges the amount of
cost that you assign to a single node is
less than equal to D and this D is what
you're shooting for D is your density
your densest subgraph so say again it's
a straightforward dual you could solve
it you could solve the Primal uh and so
useful factors in an approximate
solution of this dual also results in
approximate solution of the
Primal
so so in in order to solve D what we
would do is instead of minimizing D
we'll say let's guess
D and and then once you guess D we try
to we just have a feasibility problem we
try to find an alpha such that each Edge
gets covered and the sum of the edges
incident on on a node is less than equal
to D and this whole this these
constraints There's a constraint like
this for any node every node we're going
to call this this set of constraints
we're going to call it a poly to P so so
so we going to just think
of satisfying this constraint for every
Edge Alpha EV plus Alpha ew great equal
to 1 for every
Edge and then we're going to just call
this whole thing a polytop
p and so in in the SP my start framework
solving the
Dual you can solve the Dual by using
calls to this following
Oracle where you take y's as given so
you assume that you given
y's and then you maximize summation over
all e y of Alpha EU plus Alpha EV so you
take the dot product of Y with all the
consts that you have the sum of all the
consts that you have such that Alpha
belongs to this polytop and the width is
defined as the maximum value that any of
these left hand sides of these consts
can take subject to Alpha being in p and
so there so this guarantees that we get
an and so the guarantee that we get from
PST is that we going to get a 1 plus
Epsilon approximation in order row log
over Epsilon Square steps where row is
this
width
so the so we need to compute uh so so
what do we need to do this we need to
compute the Oracle in each expression
and the Oracle I'm going to Omit this
fact but the Oracle Maps very well to
map reduce so that's the first thing we
observe the Oracle you can solve very
easily using just one phase of map
reduce
okay so the next problem is that for
this problem as it turns out the width
is very large the width is as large as
D and since the width of this problem is
as lar large as D the first thing we do
is we add an additional constraint
to our polytop which says that Alpha is
less than equal to one okay so and as it
turns out this does not change the Dual
in any way the Dual Solutions mean
exactly the same but what it does is it
breaks down and and so there's some
there's some intuition about why that
happens but I'll skip an intuition but
what happens is that it no longer holds
that an approximate dual leads to an
approximate Primal so once again to to
give the chain of reasoning you want to
solve it using on map reduce that leads
us directly into this primal kind of
structure because these Primal dual
algorithms are well suited to going back
and forth between mapers and reducers
when we try to solve it on map reduce on
using Primal dual the width is very
large when we reduce the width it no
longer holds that an approximate dual
lead to an approximate Primal because we
have changed we have changed the Comal
structure of the Dual and the Primal and
so the next thing we do is we say well
instead of alpha less than equal to one
we say we give Alpha less than equal to
2 and then we prove the following
technical LMA that a 1 plus Epsilon
approximate solution of the Dual results
in a 1 plus Epsilon approximate solution
the Primal and then you also give a map
reduce algorithm which actually computes
the approximate Primal given the
approximate dual and all of this sounds
very complicated but I implemented it in
map say like 15 lines of code uh it
turns out to be fairly simple in terms
of performance we can show that we have
login over Epsilon squ
iterations each iteration is redu ke
complexity of dmax a sequential
complexity of order M so we are again at
the uh at the sweet spot for map reduce
in terms of our complexity and the
greedy algorithm that I didn't describ
by revi and K takes order login over
Epsilon iterations but gives a 2 plus
Epsilon approximation whereas this one
takes order log over Epsilon squ
iterations but gives 1 plus Epsilon
right so the absons a bit different the
the same idea extend the fractional
matchings and directed graphs and uh in
in in my mind uh there was a lot of work
done on solving Primal duel uh on the
Primal dual method there was a lot of
work done on distributed computing and
some of that work never really saw the
light of day and it never saw the light
of day and people kept WR and but the
theory part kept moving on and moving on
and moving on and doing more and more
pram algorithms and after some time
people actually implementing these
algorithms gave up and said that this
whole stuff is not going anywhere and
now finally it turns out that these map
reduce uh because of map reduce a lot of
those Primal dual techniques are
actually useful like for example
PST these techniques go at least 20 30
years right positively in your
programming
they they're very useful but nobody
really understands them or wants to use
them in Industry because they have sort
of people assume that this stuff is just
theoretical so I feel like there's some
value here in terms of identifying these
looking at these Primal dual techniques
again looking looking at them in the
context of problems that people actually
want to solve so for example very rarely
do people want to solve Max flows or Min
flows or uh Min cost Flows In These
large networks in Social graphs for
example but they often want to solve
things like denser subgraphs Community
detection um
uh clustering and so it'll be it'll be
really nice to sort of dust off some of
these Primal du techniques they don't
directly apply you have to take the you
have take into account the specifics of
the model I think it's it's a fruitful
Direction now the next model I want to
talk about is what I call distributed
hash table is an active distributed hash
table so distribute hash table is
something which stores key value pairs
in memory main memory on a cluster such
that machine h of key is responsible for
storing the pair key comma Val okay
where H of key is H is some hash
function and in fact dig did some
foundation work on distributed hasch
tables an active distributed hash table
in addition to lookups insertions the
DHD also supports running user specified
code on the key value pair at node H key
so instead of just like in a distribute
hashable you can fetch a value you can
write a value you can change a value um
here you can also go to that node and
say here is a piece of code just execute
this piece of code on that value and
that allows your key value pairs to be
very complex because you don't have to
fetch them all the time it allows them
to be complicated data structures and
this is like continuous map reduce
because in map reduce also you have
these key value pairs which are being
sent to reducers according to this
function H key except that this is
continuous and reducers can talk to each
other so if you continuous map reduce
which where reducers could talk to each
other you would essentially get an
active
DHD so the second example problem that
I'm going to take is rank is an early
and famous search ranking rule from Brin
atol and given a directed graph gals V
comma e with n notes M edges uh DW is a
number of edges going out of node W
Epsilon is a Teleport probability Pi V
is the page rank of node V it's a lot of
notation but most likely many of you
have seen the page rank formula enough
times and it's standard standard
notation so even without the notation it
would make
sense uh there's a simple recursive
formula for defining describing page
Rank and equivalently is the stationary
distribution of a random walk that
teleports to a random node with
probability
Epsilon and because of the consequence
as a consequence of this random walk
interpretation the monteo method can be
used to estimate page Rank and
sufficient to do R equals order login
random walk starting at every node where
each random walk terminates upon
teleport so instead of doing a long
random walk you do login random walk
starting in every node and you're going
to teleport you stop and that's going to
give you a very good estimate of page
rank now in a social network uh page
rank is actually even though it was
discovered for web networks it seems to
be the notion seems to apply even better
to social networks it's more direct you
highly reputed if other highly reputed
individuals follow you or are your
friends now one difference with the with
web is that updates of social graphs are
made in real time as opposed to a batch
craw process of web search in the web
you go out you crawl your web and you
get it back right in Social these
updates are made in real time the real
time updates are important because if
something is trending you want to find
out in real
time uh and so a goal is to design an
algorithm to update page rank
incrementally for example upon an edge
arrival in an active DHD so an active
DHT is well suited for these kind of
incremental
updates and we're going to say that the
T arrival we're going to let UT VT
denote the arriving
Edge the arriving Edge at time T so
we're going to assume that one Edge
arrives at every time time step so at
time T the T Edge arrives UT VT is the
arriving Edge DT of V is the out degree
of node V and P T of node of V is this
page rank this everything is indexed by
time T and so the two KN approaches
updating page rank one is you could run
the power iteration method from
scratch the power iteration method just
solves the whole equation by just repeat
repeatedly uh you set Pi 0 V equal to 1/
n and then you compute U uh P RV uh Us
by putting P Rus one on the on the right
and you do it Ral log n/ Epsilon time so
Ral log Epsilon sort of works for both
or you can run the monteal method from
scratch each time and the running time
is either M over Epsilon login or n over
Epsilon login depending on whether you
do power iteration or Monte Carlo and
this is that's true per Edge arrival
this is how much time it will take you
per Edge arrival theistic improvements
but nothing that provably gives
significantly better running time okay
thank you and in fact we have some lower
bounds which show that for a specific
algorithm we show that you actually for
monteo we can show that uh uh
there's a lower bond which says that
you'll need something which is
polinomial In N in the worst case even
amortized in worst case amortized would
be polinomial
Inn so so what can we do we still want
to do in do the same thing uh we still
want to do monteo so the natural way of
doing monteo is that we initialize the
active distributed hash table where we
store the social graph and we store log
and random walk starting at every node
at time t for every random walk passing
through node UT so remember that the
edge that arrived was the edge UT VT at
time t for every random walk that's
passing through node UT we shifted to
use the UT VT with probability 1/ DT UT
and what that allows us to do is to
Faithfully maintain our random Works
after arbitary Edge arrivals right so
this process is exactly monteo so this
process is exactly the same as if you
had waited till time T and then done
monteo so there's no reason to talk
about approximations because we doing
exactly monteo
and the time or the number of network
calls for each read outing is order one/
Epsilon because each random walk is one/
Epsilon long and observe that for to do
this we need the graph and the store
random walks to be available in fast
distributed memory it's a reasonable
assumption for social networks but not
necessarily for the web
graph because because of the differences
in
scale so what we're going to do is we're
going to do an average case analysis
because I said in the worst case we can
show there is an amortized lower
bound and we're going to assume that the
edges of the the graph are chosen by an
adversary but presented to us in random
order okay so the adversary choses
chooses the worst possible edges for one
for algorithm but then we take a then
somebody takes a random permutation and
then presents the random permutation to
us one by one and a technical
consequence of this uh uh uh this
uh a technical consequence of this uh
assumption is that the expected value of
the page rank After Time T of the
arriving node UT UTV is that arrive
divided by the degree of UT of UT is 1
overt okay and so the technical
consequence is sort of hard to prove but
here's a rough intuition okay we expect
P UT to be around 1n P UT is is a
station extion of page you pick a node
if you didn't know anything about the
node you would say what's this page is 1
n we expect 1/ DT UT which is one/ the
degree of the node to be around n / T
the T edges n node so so 1/ the degree
we expect to be around n / T none of
these is really correct but if we take
the ratio of these incorrect things we
get 1 / T okay and uh the random order
ensures that the expectation of this
ratio is essentially you can everything
that this rough back of the envelope
calculation is actually correct so the
expected value of the page rank divide
by the degree of an arriving node is
1/t so then let's look at the expected
number of random Works which we read out
at time T this is the expected number of
randoms that are passing through node UT
because only those are the walks that
get routed divide by the degree of UT
because that's the probability that we
are rerouting them at but the X number
of random Works passing through node UT
is just proportional the page rank of
this node Duty right because whatever we
have done up so far is has been onest
monal uh and then RN over Epsilon that's
just because these are the number of
random works we do we do R over Epsilon
random works we do R epon random Works
starting at every
node and so and that ratio that number
just turns out to be RN Epsilon / T okay
there there's nothing just arithmetic so
number of network calls you end up
making is 1 / Epsilon for routing is rn/
Epsilon Square t and the interesting
thing is the amount of extra work done
for Edge arrival goes to zero so as T
goes larger the amount of so T is the
number of edges so as as your network is
very dense the amount of work you're
doing per Edge arrival is going to zero
even for reasonable networks like this
size of Twitter when we simulate this on
Twitter this goes to one or two or
something right so so in reality you
would think that as a network is getting
bigger and bigger and denser is going
the problem gets harder and harder but
in reality the problem gets easier and
easier you're doing almost no work as a
network as denser and when you sum this
over all T the work done over all M
arrivals goes to around n/ EPS squ log
squ n and so if you're going to use the
standard Theory thing and ignore one/
epon ignore logs then this goes becomes
L linear in the number of nodes so
essentially the total amount of work you
do over all as arrival is actually less
than the number of edges in your
network and so and to compare and this
is roughly this is roughly the same
again if we ignore logs and epsilons
this is roughly the same as the amount
of work you do for n mon per Edge
arrival so the total amount of so you
took the per Edge arrival work and you
made it to move to
total so the summarize the the random
order assumption is much weaker than
assuming generative models such as
preferential attachment so if you look
at any any of these generative models
pral attachment oreni uh Community
models uh they all satisfy the random
mod
assumption so if you if you if if after
the fact you look at all possible graphs
that could be generated by professional
attachment and you fix condition on the
on on some set of edges then the set of
edges is going to arrive in random model
the so the technical consequence I can't
really given a single Network like
Twitter I can't really verify or
Facebook I can't really verify the
technical assumption is satisfied
because I'm given one graph how do I
know that the edges arrived in random
order but the technical consequence
which is all we need in the proof is
something you can verify empirically
over many many edges and that we did we
did that over Twitter it's just exactly
correct the result does not hold for
adversary arrival order and the analysis
the interesting thing is the analysis
carefully pairs an appropriate
computation data model like active
dhts uh with some sort of some sort of
minimal assumptions on The Social
Network so some directions in open
problems I think this is a big open
problem in my mind in Oracle for
personalized page L and it's is one of
those problems which so David is smiling
so maybe he's going to talk about it and
and the reason is big is because these
products which nobody makes and since
nobody makes them you don't realize that
they're missing and once such product is
personalized search so you can go on I'm
out of time which is good because now I
have an excuse but but uh if you go on
Google and you search for something like
for example if I go and search for Bahan
bahman who's the person I wrote this
paper with right nothing shows up
nothing interesting shows up uh it
should be somehow personalized to me
right if I go on Twitter and I search
for algorithms nothing interesting shows
up and so right now web search in
particular is personalized in sort of
very very trivial ways and it's a big
missing thing and I think what's missing
is in Oracle for personalized page rank
or something like personalized page rank
which can tell you not just who the top
100 people are for you in personalized
page rank but given an abary person was
that person's personalized page length
score for you uh realtime social search
and so that would that in term would
facilitate real time social search we
have made partial progress for distance
based relevance measures for there we
can do realtime social search which is
personalized but but distance is not not
as interesting as personalized page rank
mixed algorithms algorith can run on
either map reduce or active dhts or a
combination seamlessly
and I I I don't know why this is there
okay thank
you